I hope I'm wrong but I think we're
heading for a global depression you
think is gonna get that bad yeah MSNBC
would never let me say what I'm saying
there's a 7080 percent chance Trump is
gonna get reelected
you don't pivot based on President Biden
pocahontas economy Alfred a Newman the
Donald you're counting on the government
to take care of you I don't know it's an
interesting market will you guarantee it
absolutely not I made more money after
2008 and every my whole entire life
because the best time to start a
business is right after a crash
incredible
the average firefighter has about 1.2
million in pension there's nothing there
meaning what their pensions were stolen
okay be prepared because some was about
to happen and the US dollar is fake
people are scared son we're raising a
bunch of snowflakes
the people that are sick of it are not
Republicans it's everybody
they're like lemon so what can I do but
they don't change the world look what I
become
[Music]
so I've read nearly 2,000 books in my
life but this book I read was a third
book I read in my life and it completely
changed my views by the way this isn't
the first time we're sitting down with
my guest here today the last time we sat
down with him I think by attainment had
the 1200 subscribers and we were barely
getting started and then it's led to
what it is today nearly 2 million
subscribers and while at that time I
think this had sold I don't know 25
million copies I don't what the number
was Rich Dad Poor Dad has sold forty 1
million copies I suggested to Robert I
said maybe he's got to do a new book
titled fifty shades of a Rich Dad maybe
it's got a whole different market but
anyways it's good to be back with our
friends here Robert Kiyosaki thank you
so much for making it thank you
congratulations on your success yes
congrats on this 41 million are you
kidding me how does it feel knowing you
have inspired so many people around the
world tool with a simple concept a
diagram there's so many used at EB si
from an employee I'm sorry employee to
self-employed to business owner to
investor how does it feel you know and
you've impacted so many people to make
that shift that's quite humbling you
know because I almost haven't finished
school because I kept flunking out of
school cuz I can't write so to be an
international writer is a miracle I bet
your your teachers you know if they had
to see that that's taking place I wonder
what some of the critics who know you at
that time would be saying about 41
million copies today but let's talk
about some of the stuff that's going on
today you know the market is an
interesting market today I'm kind of
curious to know what you got going on
obviously you wrote a book called who
stole my pension which we'll get into
here in a minute but it's an interesting
market that was at 29 K you know you got
Breck's it's about to take place January
31st you know 2020 they're kind of going
through that to see what's gonna happen
there you got the iran-us conflict right
you got the trade war with China
you know that's taking place and there's
some war going on right now with Japan
but they're kind of getting the deal
going right you got Venezuela still
having some issues with Maduro and
Garrido with their oil you got us with
politics it's a very divisive time
with mainstream media and Trump and
impeachment and all this just all the
stuff that's going on a lot of people
see that as a scary time a market
crashes around the corner what am I
going to do I'm going to lose everything
I'm going to go through this how does
somebody like you from your lens how do
you view today's economy and what's
taking place well first of all the
reason I wrote Rich Dad Poor Dad was
because I knew this time was coming and
we have as a world I've never been here
before and so is it a spooky time damn
yet it was a is probably the most
dangerous time ever ever ever ever
there's nothing to compare it to because
there's never been a world economy
before for example you know 100 years
ago
there was a stock market crash in
England didn't affect anybody but now
the US market goes down the world goes
down so Plus with social media and all
this we're doing now and so we've never
been here before and you know I I'm
excited about it because I make more
money in crashes than I do when they go
up so but for the average person they'll
get wiped out I'm afraid that the worst
I hope I'm wrong but I think we're
heading for a global depression global
depression yeah what does it look like
depression I mean people are depressed
the economy stays down it's hard to come
back up and now the good news is is that
for those who are prepared for it like
you and you'll do better not everybody
dies on a plane cross some plane crashes
mm-hmm but the last crash in 2008 you
know I was on wolf blitzer's program six
months before Lehman Brothers went down
and I said Lehman was going down and
nobody listened but I went down and so
I've been expecting this market to go
down for quite a while and I'm concerned
about my fellow my fellow human beings
but as you know most Americans are
clueless you know they don't know what's
going on but you know you travel the
world I just I just I just got back from
Africa and China and Japan and New
Zealand people are scared you know
Australia has had a recession in 30
years
in recession but Americans are fat dumb
and happy having a good time which is
good but I'm concerned that's all I can
say I be I'd be afraid if I had kids you
know you'd be afraid about having kids
too if I had kids know it you know I
think that's an adult you can go hungry
but you don't wanna see your kids go
hungry and that's what's gonna happen
you think's gonna get that bad yeah let
me ask you this what is the biggest
factor that's going to cause that well
the reason I wrote Rich Dad Poor Dad is
the US dollar you know that's my book
over there fake which came out last year
fake money fake teachers fake assets and
the US dollars fake never they never in
the history of the world has any fake
money ever survived and we're doing the
same thing we just keep printing this
money and when I wrote Rich Dad Poor Dad
20 almost 25 years ago people said
they're no I was talking about you know
I said I said savers would be losers now
today this quantitative easing which is
contra fitting money mm-hmm and then you
have zero interest rates and people are
still saving money you nuts they just
print it I think 500 billion dollars in
September of this year because the repo
market is going down and the average guy
goes well what's the repo market they
don't know so that's why it's fake money
fake teachers fake assets are our
education system it has been my rant for
ever
why don't we teach people about money
why is it we all use money but we don't
teach people about it so that's why I'm
concerned and I wrote this book who
stole my pensions already sold out but I
wrote who stole my pension because was
the reason I wrote Rich Dad Poor Dad but
two authors here me and myself
Everett's Adelle we both had dads who
lost everything and when I was in my 20s
and my dad my poor dad lost everything
it scarred me and I said I'm never gonna
let anybody ever do that to me so I just
come back from Vietnam in 73
my dad was unemployed
part of us unemployed and he tells me to
go fly for the F and Airlines I said you
kidding me
let's go back to school get your
master's to get your PhD I said are you
kidding me here the guy is unemployed
he's got no pension it's got no paycheck
and he's telling me to go back to school
I said what learned nothing you know and
those guys who might you know my friends
who flew for United Airlines they're
broke today there's pension their
pensions were stolen USAir same thing
look at what's going on in Paris today
as we talk they're rioting millions of
people are rioting because of pensions
Japan they're rioting because of penché
terrible you see them it's terrible yeah
yeah and Americans oh how my 401k is do
I'm going G I'd be a little bit worried
but they don't know Americans love
enough fish ball here they can everybody
see is in but Americans can't see out so
like I travel the world constantly
mm-hmm
and what I see going on the world is
disturbing I was just in Argentina and I
took my kid brother there and he came
back a changed man he says you weren't
kidding where is it no it wasn't my
brother could not believe that what I
what happens in Argentina is going to
happen here it's terrible it's 12
million people working to support nine
million people in Argentina with an
inflation of 31 32 percent right now
it's it's a absolute travesty what's
going on over there in Europe and when
you look at our Gina from America like
oh my gosh is that you know Europe of
Central it's a Europe of Central America
you know when you go to Argentina it's
such a beautiful place but that's one of
the most beautiful one as our respect a
beautiful place and it's got nice hotels
food red sauce first-class everything so
why do you think sometimes you know the
thing I'm always curious about is when
we're talking about fear Robert what is
the biggest difference between fear
today versus fear fifty years ago versus
fear one hundred years ago versus fear
twenty years ago isn't this a common
thing like when market does well economy
does well a few people are prepared for
it most people kind of sit around don't
do anything about it what's changed and
is that going to be happening 50 years
from now 100
years from now we're people who
capitalize and most don't well that's a
fabulous question because you know today
when I refer to 2008 most people
remember 2008 did I mean that's when
Lehman went down horse turns 39 percent
drop yeah they they all remember it but
when I started Rich Dad Poor Dad the
only thing they had was the depression
you know I came out in nineteen nineteen
ninety-seven Rich Dad Poor Dad came out
and there were a reference points was a
depression and none of the people I talk
to remember the depression so the fear
today I think people a little bit wiser
yes because they do remember 2008 and
they do remember mm so 2008 mm mm 2008
and here we are today so I think most
people are at least kind of tuned in I
hope it doesn't come down but I'm afraid
it well that's that's what I have to say
most people more tuned in today because
it was only 12 years ago when the last
market crash happened I remember all
wait the wait was pretty ugly we started
our agency a year later in oh nine and
it's one thing you could've done
yeah but believe me had benefited us
because we got a contract with AIG at
the time and a few insurance companies
and we started growing but everybody was
scared and a part of you know the
business for us as fear sharpens
listening if you're able to monetize on
fear you can really do some stuff when
the market changes but I want to say
what you did was really really smart
because the best time to start a
business is right after a crash I made
more money after 2008 that every my
whole entire life because everybody was
hiding like little cockroaches well you
made more money after 2008 an entire
life yeah so what you know here I'm
talking about the coming depression
everybody's all yours
you're such a pessimist you know okay no
I'm excited
you know I get sexually stimulated think
about all the bargains that are gonna be
on the street you know I mean I mean
it's company Parkins everywhere but
everybody else all you're pessimistic oh
no I'm actually optimistic so anyway so
you're very smart just you know when I
study I study business guys who start
after a crash - very well most of the
time it's it's work for us you know
whether it was smart luck or wise or a
little bit of us still take it as long
as we just have met you stupid so
somebody's watching the scene okay
Robert it's you're saying this while you
know 2008 2009 Dow dropped soft and it
goes down to I don't know what the
number was it goes down to 6500 at one
point and I don't don't know the exact
month on when it it but it hits 6500
points and six and it was at 14 and it
was at 14 and I went to 65 so that's 50%
yeah you could about Ford stock at that
time I think like 75 cents or a dollar
and all these other things that took
place at the time everything was cheap
to buy right so that takes place and
then we you know we go from 6500 to
16,000 to 29,000 and I have a friend of
mine where I said hey you remember that
one book he read then throw it I don't
know if you remember Harry dent when he
wrote a book talking about the fact that
the Dow is gonna go to 42,000 etc etc
and the opposite happened right right
pull my head the great boomer yes and
then there was the other book which is
like well it's gonna be the opposite the
markets gonna tank and a market went up
so my buddy said whatever Harry dent
writes do the opposite this book hey
it's a friend of mine we're taking your
counsel except my buddy says do the
opposite and then there was another book
that was written
will you read good to great and you're
hearing all these stories he has in
there about Fannie am you know Freddie
Mac and Fannie man that book was a big
book Collins for for quite some time the
red book by Jim Collins and the
principles haven't changed but some of
the stories of the companies you know
had changed I think use Kmart and some
of these other stores so it's 29,000
right now somebody may be watching the
same
listen there's a 7080 percent chance
Trump is gonna get reelected the way
it's going right now this impeachments
not gonna go anywhere he's gonna get
reelected Joe Biden's not gonna be able
to debate against the guy Bernie has
some Bernie Bernie Bernie Bernie now
gonna let Bernie get the super-delegates
because the super-delegates are gonna go
to Joe maybe Warren maybe it's a broker
convention Bloomberg comes and he's
setting up offices all over the place
you're all over the country spending all
this money's worth fifty four billion he
can do
but there's the optimist that say Robert
I don't know I think the house is gonna
go to 35 40 45 I think it's time to
double down right now
you know I think things are gonna be
good the next four years fibers I just
don't know six years from now but I do
know four or five years from now what
would you say something like that said
well you guarantee it
absolutely not say I don't I'm not in
the stock market so I'm not the guy to
ask and I just don't trust the market
because it's so manipulative I'm not
saying you know that Bo got fake money
fake teachers fake assets the Dow this
book who stole my pension I write about
what is America's number-one export what
it is mmm-hmm toxic assets you know 2008
was was Wall Street toxic assets toxic
gas CEOs ambulances yes you know
derivatives and so what is it today
Walsh we just loaded the pensions so
this book who stole my pension it's like
I said my co-authors an SEC attorney and
he got sick and tired of seeing all
these bankers loot the pensions and get
paid bonuses and then the labor union
guys who manage the funds get paid
bonuses and the guys who manage it get
paid bonus meanwhile the workers get
screwed so when this next crash comes
it's going to be horrible
now you look at the other guy so there's
two authors Ted siddell SEC Attorney his
father was a CIA operative in Uganda and
EDI min killed his father so his family
went broke because there was no body
he couldn't collect anything because no
body no you know corpse corpse whereas
my father ran for political office
against the Governor of Hawaii and he
got crushed and the governor says your
no job no paycheck no pension so my old
man's broke so Ted and I are about the
same age and we come back he was he said
my father has no money my family's
starving my family was starving because
my father lost everything so it kind of
put us on edge you know I mean I don't
trust my government I'm not a Republican
or Democrat I like drop
but they can't save me you know Trump
Biden Sanders come in it's a cast of
characters right you got the Donald on
one side and then you got comrade
Sanders economy and then you got
Pocahontas and then you got Alfred a
Neuman butch at put a judge it's a it's
a it's a relative TV show you're
counting on the government to take care
of you wake up so you don't at all look
at it as they have an effect over your
net worth or your next moves no so so
you that's that's good you want to make
sure that number on which who's in
office or what crashes you're okay
that's the most important thing you can
do you don't pivot based on presidents
oh course not they don't affect me at
all
you don't pivot based on presidents no
I'm not a stock guy that's why okay so
I'm a real estate guy so for us I own
businesses so the rich dead company does
better in a crash an apartment houses
they always do well because people have
got someplace to live and I want oil
well it's cause people always burning
oil so I always protect my assets that
they're crash-proof so let me ask you
the average person is watching us right
now saying okay Robert I'm not like you
I don't run a company I don't have a
brand I haven't so 41 1 million copies I
don't have oil I don't have rental
properties what can I do I'm in a time
like this you're telling me the markets
gonna go in shambles here pretty soon
because of currency and we printed half
a trillion dollars of money in September
just in one month not including the
three trillion dollars we print in the
last seven years prior to that what do I
do to be prepared for time like this
well first of all everybody can do
something but they won't and that's the
problem the reason you know who stole my
pension there was plenty of money in it
but nobody did anything they just stole
it people did nothing it's like I said
the when the crash came in 2008 not one
of those guys went to jail I got paid
bonuses so there's something rotten
inside of Merrick
and I think the problem with many
Americans is they're complacent they
expect well it'll it'll heal itself
again so the thing everybody can do is
you know like um as I covered in fake my
first investment was a gold coin in Hong
Kong about a Krugerrand I was flying on
earth flying off an aircraft carrier and
Vietnam and I went to Hong Kong and I
bought a gold crew Quran the date was
1972 the reason that dates important yes
because in 1972 it was illegal for
Americans to hold gold so I just smoked
I to smuggle that little puppy into
America I put it in my pocket came off
the ship and oh my checked you know but
I felt like a criminal as I smuggled
this gold because it was illegal for
Americans to own gold after 1933 under
Roosevelt but that gold coined today is
worth almost two thousand dollars the
one gold coin yeah I still haven't what
you pay for it 50 cent $50 $50 to $2,000
1972 yeah I just sat there so I have
milk and so I never because I understand
money that you know quantitative
counterfeiting and zero interest rates I
don't trust a dollar so for most of my
life I'm saved gold and silver and not
ETF sighs take a pill gotta pay you know
I know that's your well but in my world
is completely into the hard assets so I
have millions and gold coins and sulfur
coins I just kept saving it because I
don't trust the dollar so everybody can
buy a silver coin today for twenty bucks
a silver gold a silver eagles twenty
bucks but how many people will go to a
coin shop and buy it probably none less
than 1/10 of 1% of Americans own
precious metals and silver today is 50%
below its all-time high
so silver is the biggest bargain sitting
in the market as we speak today it's
about 20 boxes should go to 50 so at 20
bucks and I tell my friends I go think
about it that
the problem so everybody can afford 20
bucks
you know kids confirm 20 bucks the thing
is people won't do it and then you know
that too when you deal with people most
people are pretty sedentary you know
they they want to do the same old thing
sure happy nothing's gonna happen
I just try to scare me but I was talking
to my doctor last night you know he says
you've been saying this stuff for 25
years I never listened to you
that's it yeah well this is not what do
I do because his 401k you know as we
cover in this book here the average
firefighter has about 1.2 million in
pension there's nothing there what do
you mean their payouts come about 1.2
million the average the average
firefighter retiree has at one point too
much that's how much like I'd paid
outright but there's nothing there it's
a problem meaning what meaning they
don't have the money to pay the benefits
for stolen it was stolen by Wall Street
so how's that Spiro fuy Altis blue house
they're gonna be fulfilled because I
don't understand that said you said by
2050 two billion the retirees will be
above the age of 60 what was a stat you
said about okay today is 2020 right
mm-hmm in ten years twenty thirty two
billion baby boomers across the world
will retire Japan's broke argentinos
broke china's broke italy's broke
Germany's broke all discs old guys are
retiring and the stock market I was at I
live in a fairly exclusive place in
South Carolina and I was talking to my
friends there ha we love Trump we love
drop stock market's an all-time high
and I said yeah but so it's our debt
all-time high say they watch the stock
market they don't watch the debt and the
repo mark and the repurchase market is
the biggest one of the biggest markets
in the world and the Fed is bailing that
one out now so the average Americans
watching the stock market but not what
what's really going on so that's why I
wrote who stole my pension
so that means retirees their kids
taxpayers will pay for the heist so so
so let me ask you this o1 as you said
there by coins
whether it's like all coins
you don't buy call coins to make money
you like all coins because a dollar is
gonna go down so I don't trust the
dollar any time Buffett says I'm
evermore Buffett says I'm buying thirty
about thirty five million dollars of
silver I don't know if you remember that
anybody look okay be prepared because
sums about to happen
yeah right if he buys gold just be ready
in the next six 1224 months he's
anticipating some kind of a crash to be
taking place he's right now in cash
because that's smart yeah he's
anticipating something to have yeah to
buy up businesses and rebuild them he
does that all the time and then he's
gonna go in after the crap he's gonna go
up to the crash now the the tragedy is
which I cover in fake and just all my
pension so you have this defined
benefits which are police officers
firefighters and schoolteachers and
Union guys like the UPS drivers you know
the pretty smart guys was UPS drivers
they were getting a five thousand a
month pension they get my hair cut down
to eight hundred fifty a month from five
thousand screw them all now this is
every one of them Robert when they're
saying this from five thousand to 850
yep how can they do that well to look at
my friends why airline pilots lost
everything they stole the pensions
nobody talks about it
US air they stole the pensions the team
serves that got stolen by Wall Street
and nobody knows RB not insured well our
business and she's not insurer EBG see
right Pension Benefit Guaranty they're
broke the defined benefit which is the
DB pension plan teachers fire fire
schoolteacher I don't have one you
probably own have one no that was the
Industrial Age pension plan
my father's pension plan the PBGC was to
back it up today as we talk if they had
to bail out the defined benefit pension
it's an air from nine trillion to
seventeen trillion dollar shortfall
look at CalPERS California state
pension one trillion dollars underwater
CalPERS alone and then now he got the
401k guy
the average 401k at least a
schoolteacher has a million - average
401k guy has 65 thousand by retirement
the average 401k guys sixty-five
thousand my retirement and so one day
what what the actuarial is do you know
you know those guys right the guys I put
the numbers together they lump in the
guy with one percent and with a guy I
got nothing mm-hmm and it comes out
every Americans a millionaire because
the upper 1% there's so of course they
lift everybody else up if they take the
top 5% out those numbers will be a whole
different story
yeah yeah you can you you had those
billionaires and there shows the numbers
to be much better yeah it looks really
good when you average it you know but
when you look at the case by case so the
average the average 401k guy is
sixty-five thousand to a hundred K when
they retire that's just America so
remember Paris is rioting right now
because they're trying to cut their
pensions Japan's writing Hong Kong
writing Argentina Indonesia everybody's
the old guys like me are gonna suck the
system dry so I end it's gonna bring
down the market it's gonna be pensions
cuz cuz I can't get it I wish I could
get younger but I can't so this guy is
getting older and older every day that
goes by we get closer to the edge and
they're like lemmings you know so that's
so that's why my doctor my medical
doctor yes I should have listened to you
ten years ago well I still got time okay
so one is some kind of a precious metal
is one has form for money for money as a
form of investment long-term no it's not
even of investment it's an insurance
policy because the dollar is gonna go
down
so you buy it and you resell it or you
buy it or you keep it keep it
okay so long-term you buy it and you
keep it and you said it's I never sell
okay so you buy it and you keep it okay
so that's one so what else can I do
today
if I know these bad times are coming I'm
a regular guy what do i what else do I
do to position myself better
well what a person does is what they can
do and since the average person is no
financial education they can't do much
so like hey you know I can short the
market I'll make more take more money as
it shorts coming down so I'm looking
forward to it but the average pensioner
they're handcuffed they can't get out if
they take the money out they're
penalized 30% they screwed them hmm
they screwed everybody that's Wall
Street the government and all these guys
so what can I do I'm one of them what do
I do this would go back to employee
self-employed business owner
investor like the go find a business go
start a business go reposition yourself
career-wise you know is there a a one to
three step process on what I can do to
be prepared for it well the next book
I'm writing with a guy named Jim records
currency wars and all that next book I
read is called the Ravens and Gemini see
eye to eye
you know definition of intelligence he
says you should have gold as you have
silver you should have a museum quality
artwork I don't have any of the museum
quality artwork yeah and realistic
income-producing real estate like you
have I have a friend in Panama he has an
avocado farm he's he says I got out of
he's a Canadian I got out of Canada
because Canada's no worse shape than
America this guy's pretty he's a you
know a bond trader so he's sitting in
Panama growing avocados is because
people have to eat another guy's friend
of Mines crying blueberries but another
friend of mine he moved up to see yeah
he was from Seattle scuse me he had a
big house his kids all moved out so he
converted the kids bedrooms into
one-bedroom apartments so he put a
kitchen and he put a toilet inside his
little bedrooms and so he now rinse out
four bedrooms he's making more money
today than ever before because a lot of
workers commute to Seattle so they come
in they check in they come in on Sunday
night the check off Friday afternoon
that's a little house it's making more
money so the point is everybody can do
something
but you got to figure out what you can
do yeah so to me what I take away from
what you just said right there's a use
your creativity there too to kind of
position yourself away whatever that
could be just think outside the box and
be creative
wait don't short stocks if you've never
shorted a stock because you know how
dangerous that hundred-percent cuz it
could flip on you and then you're Oh
short that goes up yeah you're out
you're out especially I remember back in
o1 when the margin then 99 when the
margins were margin calls were coming up
I think there was even a movie named
margin called a 15 years ago but how
about industry wise so it right now when
you're looking at the last so don't look
at yourself as who you are today let's
go back to you're out of the Marines
okay you're I don't know 32 years old
okay you're 30 to 35 years old you've
just started a family okay you're just
getting married you're just about to
have a kid you don't have a lot of money
to yourself maybe you got 20 30 40 50
grand you know you got something going
on but you know this is coming and
you're watching the saying okay this
makes sense to me I buy into it this
time is coming how do I pivot now with
industries that I can look at that could
be good ways to position myself for 5 10
15 years from now again if this is
Robert 30 to 35 how would you position
yourself at that time you don't have a
lot of money well you and I are
educators really mm-hmm
and there's something you should know
about you know technology all these
cameras hmm
okay it's called The Linde effect this
nauseum teleport about it he says
anything that's been new in the last 20
years will be gone in 20 years what's
going to survive is alled so everybody
thinks what technology is going to make
it what survived as all it's the reason
called and solar will survive because
it's old Bitcoin may not survive because
it's new so I'm not saying I'm not
telling you what to buy I'm just telling
you how to think so Nassim Taleb
has a book called anti fragile which is
good ciliary hello it's fantastic he's a
smart guy but he writes about you know
how we have in school today we're
raising snowflakes you have to have safe
rooms
you can't trigger it can't say anything
you know so we're raising a bunch of
snowflakes and it says the guy that's
gonna survive is somebody who is not
fragile anti fragile so what he says is
this whatever doesn't kill you will make
you stronger so he says when you go to
the gym and you pump weights you push a
hundred pounds that means the next time
you're pushing Mike walk 105 so bad
times will make the straw stronger and
bad times will make the snowflakes
weaker some of the thing is good you
know as my Mexican friends were saying
get some cojones you know get some balls
out there and get ready for whatever's
coming don't run in hide and so a trump
sure to save me or Bernie's gonna save
me so the big thing this anti fragile is
good but another thing they should know
is the bigger something gets ier banks
the more fragile so the too-big-to-fail
companies are more fragile for fragile
more fragile more fragile and the and
the companies I Will Survive
I like our companies because we're small
nimble yeah we make quick adjustment
which moves the bigger they are the
harder they fall
right when I have Nassim Taleb anti
fragile Black Swan skin in a game
yes.can in the game great book right
thinker you know so you're working for a
big company like Google you might be
safe today but you might be gone
tomorrow whereas you're a little startup
you might have a better chance I'm not
saying what it is but there's something
everybody can do like I said everybody
can buy a twenty to twenty dollar silver
piece everybody can afford twenty bucks
will they do it no I'll be at Starbucks
sucking it down instead so what would
the 30 to 35 year-old Robert Kiyosaki do
right now what industry would you be
looking at today to make your money I'd
be in this business you would still be
in this business education look at this
content look at what we're doing
Wow look at what we're doing you know I
mean I have I have several YouTube
channels going out I don't know what I'm
doing but I have young people doing it
morning mm-hmm
so I be with techno and now the cameras
will be obsolete but you can bind your
camera turn I mean I wouldn't invest in
the camera I'd buy a camera but I would
invest in the company you no matter them
huh it's it's how you think about this
right now
so just know that those who are in big
companies would think they're safe might
be at the most at risk you know you're
working for Bank of America or Wells
Fargo you might be at risk so you would
position yourself more with stars well
the bigger something incredible advice
by the way I'm not gonna like to give it
I just no I think it's great counsel
though but it's great perspective yeah
now you're given okay so so far Council
on what to do with the marketplace is
come when we talk about some precious
metals silver and a gold buy um never
sell keep them okay great you know find
a way to be creative kind of like your
friends that house four bedrooms kids
are gone
put it bathroom there sell them you're
making random you're making money then
the next one is don't work for a big
company work for more nimble smaller
companies and maybe content creation
education use the platforms that we have
right there's something you said which
was very interesting to me you said the
fact that we are printing money we're in
debt and your friends when you're in
South Carolina at this exclusive
community they're saying I love Trump
the markets doing great it's thousand
twenty nine thousand and they said but
also the debt is that the highest it's
ever been so here's a way I see this an
accused on how you process this do you
think the reason why we're not really
having the conversation about the big
elephant in the room which is the you
know say hundred trillion dollars have
unpaid the commitments that we have not
including the twenty two trillion
dollars a bit that we have we have
Medicare Social Security of all this
unpaid commitments that we may not
including that that we have to Russia to
Japan not Russia to China to Japan all
this stuff that we have to pay for right
do you think the reason why none of the
presidents are really talking about it
is because if they do it's not a
eight-year figs so whatever they do if
they campaign on it it's a twenty forty
or fake so because they have no
influence to fix it and so they're just
kind of letting you go to the next
president they can't fix it do you think
that's why they're not talking about it
and all they're doing is inflaming
people you know I mean that they just
talk about what Trump in a zipper the
immigration and impeachment and all this
because they can't do anything so so
does that say that the current model of
how we pick presidents is that an
effective model because you know if they
can't do anything like why would I want
to campaign around paying off the
national debt when there's nothing I can
do about it in four years because the
GDP is what three point six trillion
national debt is twenty two trillion
even if I took the GDP and I made no
money no one make any money everybody
pay taxes 100 percent three point six
trillion in four years I wouldn't even
have to did that we have no and that's
why you know Pocahontas Elizabeth Warren
talks about tax the rich Hale say tax
the rich well I hate to tell you this
but the rich don't pay taxes I covered
and fake it's it's pretty pathetic you
know I mean it's legal you're laughing
at what though what are you laughing at
how stupid our reporter sorry I mean
that's why these guys here I love what
these guys are doing because they would
never let me say this on CNBC MSNBC
would never let me say what I'm saying
but now because of YouTube and all these
you know realized up yeah we can say
what we want it's right on speech except
in school I can't say anything but I
think yeah this is the best time of all
but it's also the most dangerous and
that's what nauseum tell was talking
about if you're anti fragile if somebody
punches you and you fall down you go
thank you I'm gonna company back
stronger you know that's kind of what's
gonna save you but if you're what the
guy who is oh you have to put me in a
safe room and you can't say anything
triggers me one of those guys those kids
say I don't want them you know they're
not gonna make it did there's something
happening though here's here's there's
something happening right now that's
very weird I don't know if you watch the
Golden Globes is that what it is the
Golden Globes Ricky Ricky what's his
less Gerace did you watch Ricky Gervais
sirs monologue at the Golden Globes
no oh my it's eight minutes after this
with your wife watches eight minute clip
I'll text at you if you want okay
it is absolutely incredible because what
I notice happening with politics today
is the snowflakes are given birth to
people who are so sick of it and the
people that are sick of it are not
Republicans it's everybody it's like
because now the snowflakes are kind of
offending Democrats we're probably can't
say this you can't say that you can't
say this community can't say that
community can't say that and the
communities are like leave me alone I
just want to tell a joke right
and so I almost think today let me tell
you a Rodney Dangerfield joke no I could
never tell it that guy was so funny if
it was they'd hang them today they would
yeah that would probably happen today
but you know today's comedians are like
listen man I feel like I'm handcuffed
let me tell the damn joke but I think
content creators are pissing off ABC CNN
Fox NBC all those guys I was just on a
vacation was team Burke NBCUniversal he
says we're in the spot right now he's
saying that he's resigning next year the
biggest media company in America he says
you can I thought about my little
youtube chance that you guys are killing
us he said you guys are killing us yeah
this is the NBC CEO saying you guys are
killing us streaming and all this they
can't compete they're spending money to
lose money and by the way then they just
started they're launching a streaming
company something like that NBC just
announced it right yeah yeah and and in
end of spring and by the way Disney's
streaming company after two months is
already valued at a hundred billion
dollars it's all [ __ ] it's valued at
a hundred billion dollars already based
on what business and Satre and some of
the experts are saying so you know but
going back to it with the debt what how
do you get elected today to president
first of all say you're campaigning on
debt and you cam your campaign is we
have to pay off this twenty two trillion
dollars of that and you bring awareness
to listen no matter what we're talking
about this that is company you think you
love your kids or your grandkids here's
what they're gonna be facing this the
situation they're gonna be in and I'm
gonna sit down one be like oh my gosh
okay let me see what this presidential
candidate Robert Kiyosaki has to say
boom you get
like that you win your president what
are you doing with the long-term debt to
be able to pay that off longer-term
resign I don't like it I don't say way
out Roger you're saying there's no way
out with the dead do you see a way I
don't see what I don't I'm cute know
what you I don't know how the Matt
doesn't make sense to me that's why what
what talib is saying does in you want to
get smaller right now you don't want to
get bigger you know it's almost like
being a Navy SEAL you won't get into a
small team like at-rich that we have a
small team we trust everybody we know
everybody been working together most of
us 25 years and we don't let anybody
else has a little tight little group so
small is bigger not big as bigger small
is bigger now that really better small
is better make it one more thing that's
that's going on which I just because I
like to study trends back in the dark
ages every little town had a church in
Europe and Asia no they all had this
little church right everybody rallied
around God or Jesus or Buddha what are
they really mm-hmm
then turned the Industrial Age they're
rallying around like the war heroes like
the you know the Marine Corps that the
Marines raising the flag on Iwo Jima and
robert e lee and useless as grant so it
went from agrarian age of religious to
industrial age with valor or heroes you
know it is an information hmm the victim
hmm we worship the victim when they saw
you know like they're tearing down
robert e lee statue mm-hmm now i know
i'm not for slavery but why are they
tearing that down that was history
you know everybody's a victim today
everybody's a victim you know so my
friend and all they say well we should
give the blacks back their money we
should pay him slave and who's that
good luck what about the American Indian
they got their land taken - what about
the Japanese we got locked away in
internment camps
so everybody now you raise your head I'm
a victim
around you I'm not saying it's right to
be a vet yes it's not right to pick on
people but today the people we were are
worshipping our victims look at when
that Supreme Court justice was the woman
says he raped me but she couldn't
remember that he raped her son Kevin oh
oh yeah I'm quite holy the poor guy she
accuses him but she can't remember and
everybody just jumps all over the guy I
thought you were innocent until proven
guilty but today if you say you did you
said something you said something mean
and then this the whole world wants a
jump on you because you created a victim
so what's gonna bring America down is
the victim mentality and we're in the
middle of it that's Bernie Sanders as a
LSC that's all of these guys who's just
oh look at all the victims we got look
at all the homeless look at all this
look at the student loan debt I'm going
yeah look at it but giving them all
money is not gonna solve the problem how
do we get here what's that how did we
get here I don't know you know my
standard Pat answer is no financial
education in schools what do they teach
you about money so everybody knows in
1971 Nixon took the dollar off the gold
standard that mean fake money that's my
cut fake money fake teachers fake asses
as soon as they could print money
anytime throughout history they printed
money the money disappeared it went
broke every country that printed money
went broke were quite broke us is going
down Japan is going down
Europe's going down South America is
going down Mexico's in serious trouble
look at Venezuela the richest oil
country in the world they're going down
Zimbabwe going down because we're run by
these clubs you know club kleptomaniacs
or something they call politicians
memorising same as a who stole my
pension the same guys that robbed the
world are robbing their pensions highly
educated elites I went to Harvard went
to Yale went to MIT I'm smarter than you
I know everything let me
take your money that's what we are today
they're all poor dads would think
they're smart you meet guys like that
right because they got their PhD they
think they're smarter than Jesus you
know they make me nauseous
yeah feeling's mutual yeah they're
filled that they're all over the place
in the financial industry by the way you
seem everywhere yeah so so so your your
answer to the long-term debt there's no
solution
you don't think there's no my solutions
always the same pull back in create your
own little fire team I'm a marine you
know we just create a little fire team I
have my accountants my attorneys my
bankers my oh I have my little team go
smaller put your own team together but
I'm telling a country wise what's that
I'm talking as a country I can I'm not
gonna I can't fix that I can fix I can I
can save myself
what if Trump Donald Trump called
president truck calls you to be as a
counsel how do we get rid of this debt I
thought would you say I can't be part of
advice because I think I don't think
nice wait I still hunker down but how
would you solve it for me if he wanted
you I wouldn't or you wouldn't do it oh
why should I
I'm gonna get rich when it falls down so
it's irrelevant to you so you're simply
looking at it from the libertarian
standpoint of I'm gonna take care of
myself
and that's what I can control and I have
my team to help me with that everything
else is out of my control I'm not
touching it yeah but there's one thing
that's different
Marines fight those teams I'm on fire
team I have the best accountant the best
attorney that's banker you know you
gotta have politicians on your team too
so if you hang up on the average guy has
a financial planner if you get our
politicians on your team - yep Trump is
my friend governor's my friend city
councilman's my friend God play the game
don't change the world change yourself
that's why I say to every person out
there now if you don't know anybody
let's say you're an employee of Google
you're screwed because you don't know
anything
who's your accountant who's your
attorney can you read a financial do you
know do you know how to trade a stock do
you not do you know how to short a stock
but my team can so smaller is better at
this point in time smaller is better at
this um how do you think how do you
think president Trump is I know UNM
brought a book together to why we want
is it why we want you to be rich and
Midas touch in Midas touch which by the
way I read why we want you to be rich
and I have not read the Midas touch but
I read why we want you to be rich yeah
you guys were two books together I
remember that and I'm not Republican or
Democrat I'm just we wrote together as
teachers like we're teaching right now
I'm not trying to sell anything mm-hmm
and and this was actually a good book I
read how are you seeing how he's doing
right now but if you're looking at him
from the outside how was he doing right
now as a president I think he's doing
great
personally you think he's doing great
but you know he's got too many knives
after him right now hmm yeah but you
know if he he's got you're talking to
China he's at least talking to me
talking to Kim jong-un he's talking to
Putin he's talking to people he goes to
Davos and he talks to people Obama not
Republican Democrat Obama pissed
everybody off did you know when Obama
pulled up to China
nobody met him but they were all at the
carpet for Trump when when Obama talked
to Putin they went they got into a fight
so the so the so you know Trump is a
kind of a dictator yes but do you
dictator talk to a teacher'
you don't need a nice guy to talk to him
dictator Obama's a nice guy from Hawaii
I'm sure he's a nice guy you know but
see they laugh at him and besides he's a
guy there was a there was a book called
Lucifer's banker it was Obama who paid
Iran 150 billion dollars
and that money came out of Switzerland
and I met the Swiss banker we released
the money and Obama released the money
150 billion it didn't do any good
no Hamas got it
they laugh at him dude I mean when you
were in school if there was a bully to
being nice to the bully help no no you
know you go up and punch it out or run
away but you don't try and talk him out
of being a bully I think well hey Ossie
could yeah she's pretty cute yeah I
thought to her but it's like schoolyard
right that's what it is so I was never
the smartest guy I wasn't the toughest
guy I played football and all this but I
hung out with the guys were tight you
know where's a little an old tight group
got through school you think he's gonna
get reelected yeah he's gonna do really
well unless something happens if you
know I mean any plans to writing another
book together um we're going to in 2015
then he called me and he says uh guess
what I'm running for president and he
announced it on my radio show I was the
first guy said well congratulations good
luck and I'm gonna stand away from you
said almost stay away from you as a
target do you know yet all the seasons
right there was like 300 Caesars only
like 20 dieded a natural death the rest
are all murdered that's what Allah
bestowed lets him talk he says the
bigger you get the bigger target you get
this is the most successful company is
like Switzerland who's the president no
one knows but every country where you
know the president they're just big
they're fat they're bloated and the most
successful countries are small like
Singapore so that's why you know you're
all there guys so if you're small and
listen to this program to know I would
say you just pull your horns in wait for
the crash but have your team together
you know even in I trained as a Marine
sniper even
we had a fire we had designated snipers
with one of the teams we never go by
themselves and in school they teach you
to be the a student do it all by
yourself
well the a student's our role in the
world they don't know anything whereas I
have my little fire team you know my
accountants my attorneys my bankers my
real estate guys my financial planners
we're kicking ass because we stay small
we stay low let me ask you this question
when you're talking about that team when
you're putting your team together what
are some things you look for as a team
and what does it take to build a
stronger bond with you it takes time
okay that's yeah you know it does
you know people when it comes to money
people lie you know so it takes time to
build that trust can you trust this guy
under fire that's why I love the Marine
Corps you know we may not have liked
each other I have I went to battle royal
marines I could trust so take some time
to put a team together yeah and a lot of
flakes out there too so like a couple of
my partners we're 40 years together 40
years together we know each other like
brothers it's the most important thing
is trust confidence loyalty integrity
diligence carve on my back Robert do you
consume content or no hmm do you consume
content what's that content online do
you consume content oh yeah I study
constantly what content are you
consuming well I love YouTube you know
I'm always on there checking you know
I'm listening
if somebody says X and other guy says
why I listen to both I want to know both
sides that's what I love about YouTube
again I can check something like this
this Bitcoin versus gold argument you
got Peter shift and got Max Keiser hmm
you know I listen to both guys so you
know shift trashes Bitcoin and all this
stuff it doesn't hurt to listen to both
sides so that's why I love you do
consume content oh god yeah I'm staying
cause any final thoughts before we wrap
up anything we should be thinking about
right now if that last words I'll give
to you on what somebody ought to be
thinking about right now with the
current economy in current place that
we're in well again I love what nauseum
tal a broken okay you got to be anti
fragile today
a snowflake and our schools are pumping
out snowflakes in mass and I hope your
kid isn't one of them because that we
screwed the kids yes the student loan
debt is now bigger than 1.6 trillion is
now bigger than the subprime debt we've
screwed everybody including our kids and
that's why there's no financial
education in school that's why
everybody's fake I wouldn't trust the
school teachers advice for anything nice
people my whole family of school
teachers they don't know anything about
money
nothing they want their pension and
paycheck who would you listen to if
you're saying don't listen to teachers
who would you listen to let's look a
list of guys like you I listen to Max
Keiser I listen to a chef I listen to
Talib Bala Sants all the whack jobs also
you know cuz it might be right well I
love about YouTube is so fast you know
I'm all something like ten minutes you
know yeah okay good got much out of a
whack job so I have accepted this the
second time we set them to get obviously
every time we sit down with them the
conversation it's just fascinating to to
get into Roberts brain and Roberts mind
we're gonna put the link to all the
books below Robert we're gonna put the
link below for who stole my pension and
rich that poor that and since you
mentioned Nasim tell it five times in
today's episode I'm gonna put the books
of Nassim Taleb as well below and by the
way while you're watching this I'd like
to get you to send a message to Robert
Kiyosaki send him a tweet over here
we'll put his handle their minds gonna
be right here tell us what you took
what's your biggest takeaway from this
episode with Robert Kiyosaki and if you
haven't subscribed to the channel please
do so Robert thank you so much thank you
does that work yes thank you will do
bachelors success thank you thank you so
much thank you
you
[Music]